bien merci messieur de de votre présence
nous reprenons donc le travail de la
commission je me permets de de vous
rappeler
que nous sommes dans le cadre d'une
mission d'information menée par la
commission des lois mise en place par la
commission des lois avec pour objectif
d'appréhender un peu précisément ce qui
s'est passé au moment des ce que l'on
qualifie des émeutes du fin juin début
juillet dernier bien sûr que notre
travail porte
sur par nature les fonctions régaliennes
qui sont les nôtres affaires de Sécurité
de justice c'est très bien mais nous
souhaitons
élargir la compréhension de des
événements peut-être même pour avoir des
propositions législatives ou
réglementaires ou pas de propositions du
tout en tous les cas bien des constats
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous auditionnons j'allais dire assez
largement et donc merci de de votre
présence cet après-midi les collègues de
la commission des lois sont sont
présents cet après-midi dans cette
grande salle pourquoi cette grande salle
avec un monde que vous pourriez
considérer comme pas suffisant mais
parce que nos auditions se font
habituellement ici pour des raisons de
facilité et de qualité de la salle par
rapport à notre salle de la commission
des lois qui est beaucoup plus modeste
naturellement on est retransmis là et
nous sommes par ailleurs ici retransmis
sur le site internet du Sénat ce qui
n'est pas possible commission des lois
d'où cette salle voilà comme ça les
choses sont parfaitement claires et
d'autres collègues pourront arriver
évidemment en cours d'audition je vais
vous laisser messieur Joda Mohamed et
Rocher vous êtes sociologue alors j'ai
pas le détail de des lieux où vous vous
professez si je puis dire vous
travaillez je pouvez vous présenter et
puis dire de comment vous où vous
travaillez vous êtes naturellement qu'on
comprenne bien les choses et puis je
vais vous laisser la parole
immédiatement dans l'ordre que vous
aurez peut-être prévu entre entre vous
je sais pas ce que vous avez décidé si
vous avez décidé quelque chose ou pas au
quel cas celui qui voudra prendre la
parole en premier la prendra bien
volontier voilà je je vous laisse
débuter monsieur rocher alors le micro
il faut appuyer sur le bouton rouge qui
est sur à côté du micro voilà OK puis
après il faut le dactiver
oui alors je suis désigner parce que
j'ai fait une
petite présentation que je voulais aussi
laisser comme support parce queelle est
ça les sourcé donc on sait un peu de
quoi je parle donc moi je suis directeur
de recherche au
CNRS je travaille à sciencep à Grenoble
et euh je travaille depuis assez
longtemps sur les questions de de police
sur la délinquence des des jeunes et
puis sur les émeutes parce que j'ai
connu les émeutes évidemment de de 2005
non pas comme participant mais comme
comme analyste c'était un
événement mondial lui aussi hein c'est
un événement considérable et à l'époque
le Centre d'analyse
stratégique avait été chargé de rendre
un rapport car qui est toujours
disponible euh qu'on avait fait avec un
administrateur de l'INC monsieur Morel
et puis un gendarme qui était détaché au
au centre casazel de de mémoire voilà
donc on avait travaillé sur les sur ce
sur ce sujet alors euh je me suis dit là
que j'allais choisir un petit temps un
angle assez fermé une présentation
courte pour qu'on puisse discuter
et donc je me suis là je vais essayer
d'avancer je sais pas si ça va marcher
sil faut cliquer il y a toujours un
est-ce que c'est par ICI ou est-ce que
c'est par là ou par ici on sait
jamais incertitude dans le
clic mais est-ce on sait pas où est le
capteur qui reçoit le petit signal en
fait c'est ça le
truc
bon c'est Stord ah peut-être
ça absolument pas répondre est que vous
pouvez avancer pour moi s'il vous plaît
la première prés première slide et puis
comme ça si c'est celui-là s'il accepte
de il accepte oui voilà moi je je pense
que je vais réussir c'est celui c'est
celui-là ben j'ai appuyé sur le mauvais
en plus évidemment donc voilà en
regardant
le l'importance du du rôle de de la
police dans le déclenchement des des
émeutes et dans leur résorption
éventuelle et si je regarde la
littérature internationale parce qu'
alors évidemment la France est avec la
Grande-Bretagne le pays d'Europe qui a
connu le plus d'émeutes c'est le seul
qui connaît des émeutes nationales
c'està-dire qui échappe au périmètre
d'une commune à l'exception de de la
Grèce en 2008 mais sinon la
particularité c'est pas les émeutes en
France la particularité c'est
l'envergure
géographique que prennent les émeutes et
le fait qu'elles deviennent des
phénomènes nationaux voilà donc il y a
dans les pays occidentaux il y a la
France le Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis
principalement en parallèle du mouvement
des droits civiques et puis y a desutes
qui se reproduisent mais à l'échelle
d'une grande ville comme comme Los
Angeles bon et c'est des pays qui
évidemment ont rien à voir d'ailleurs ça
me fait ça me fait dire c cette chose là
c'est que en fait c'est pas une question
de modèle de société c'est pas une
question de modèle d'état c'est pas une
question de société communautaire ou pas
parce que la France et le Royaume-Uni
sont deux pays qui ont des modèles
politiques administratif complètement
différents à tous les
égards c'est pas ça qui donne lieu aux
c'est pas les modèles c'est les
pratiques en fait c'est au niveau des de
ce qui se passe au niveau des des des
situations de d'interaction al il y a
deux d'après la littérature et je pense
que ça s'applique assez bien à la France
il y a deux grands mécanismes de
déclenchement
un mécanisme que je vais appeler direct
peut-être par par facilité c'est euh
brutalité policière ou décès au cours
d'une opération de
police probablement parce que ça produit
un choc moral extrêmement important et
on dit que ce choc est médiatisé
techniquement c'estàd qu'il est il est
lié à deux autres facteurs qui sont qui
sont eux mêmes l'identification avec le
profil de la personne qui a été tué si
on la connaît personnellement si c'est
quelqu'un de la mme monté d'escalier ou
du même quartier on est particulièrement
affecté ça ça provoque une mobilisation
et si on appartient au même groupe socio
professionnel ou ethnique on est
également
particulièrement affecté donc on va voir
comment comment ça marche mais je pense
que c'est des choses que vous savez déjà
et puis il y a un deuxième ensemble des
faits que je vais qualifier ici
d'indirect et qui sont plutôt une
accumulation de frustration les anglais
il disent strain c'est comme un un
ressort qu'on comprime et qui accumule
de l'énergie d'autant plus qu'on le
comprime qui à un moment donné va va
relâcher son son
énergie qui provoque cette cette
multiplication des petites frustrations
plus petites frustrations va va
engendrer une diminution de la confiance
dans la police qui va elle elle-même
devenir un facteur de déclenchement
parce que la police aura plus
l'autorité autorité au sens réel du
terme au sens euh la force morale qui
fait qu'on est écouté pas l'autorité au
sens de la coersion euh elle a plus
l'autorité en fait pour freiner le
mouvement des meut voilà c'est c'est les
deux grands mécanismes qu'on qu'on va
retrouver dans les différents pays
occidentaux alors
euh savoir ce que c'est une émeute c'est
pas non plus extrêmement évident c'està
que comme on regarde les les émeutes
géantes j'ai envie de dire les émeutes
nationales comme en 2023 comme en 2005
comme en 92 à Los Angeles avec 50 60
millions de dollars de destruction là
oui on dit oui là on voit bien ce que
c'est qu'une émeute mais en fait il y a
énormément de phénomènes d'une beaucoup
plus petite intensité qui se produisent
donc moi j'avais proposé de dire qu'on
pouvait imaginer qu'il y avait une
émeute sil y avait une concentration
suffisante dans le temps et l'espace de
destruction et de dégradation et il y a
quelques autres phénomènes qui viennent
de s'y ajouter confrontation physique et
parfois usage d'armes mais c'est surtout
un phénomène de con tion dans l'espace
si vous prenez par 100 feux de poubelle
vous les distribuz en îledefance il y a
pas d'meut vous prenez les mêmes 100
feux de poubelle et vous les rassembleer
à clichi un jour donné là vous parlez
d'meutes donc la désignation du terme
desmeutes c'est un phénomène de
concentration des des incidents dans
l'espace et dans le temps c'est pas un
phénomène numérique pur c'est pas une
question de quantité c'est question de
quantité avec des un certain nombre de
conditions voilà et et ça ça ça amène à
dire que en fait les émeutes c'est pas
sont pas des phénomènes sont des
phénomènes qui sont de type continu un
peu comme les marais il y en a plus ou
moins parce qu'il y a toujours un fond
et c'est enregistré par la statistique
de de police je venir tout à l'heure
toujours un fond de destruction et de
dégradation en permanence est-ce qu'on
on va parler des meutes quand la
variation de cette quantité de
dégradation et de destruction par
rapport à une date de de référence est
suffisante suffisante qu'elle est
suffisamment élevée voilà donc on va
regardarder en fait des des variations
d'un phénomène qui est en lui-même le
terme émeut en il renvoie pour sa
qualification pénale uniquement à une
somme d'infraction que le le droit pénal
caractérise destruction dégradation
différents types de dégradation de BI
privés de BI public et cetera et c'est
important encore une fois de dire ça
parce que la plupart des des phénomènes
d'meutes euh sont petits ils sont ils
sont pas gros
ok ça c'était ma petite définition euh
bon pour la police là j'entends par
police les les agents qui ont des des
uniformes et qui répondent à une
autorité civile donc je laisse de côté
toute la question des polices privées
qui sont extrêmement importantes mais
qui qui ici va pas me vont pas me
concerner alors je rappelle aussi une
chose une propriété des émeutes ça c'est
pas simplement français là je montre un
certain nombre de départements français
euh en 2005 où on voit ici le nombre de
véhicules brûlés par jour dans
différents départements et c'est qu'on
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'en fait dans
chacun des départements on retrouve en
fait la même structure le même cycle
temporel et c'est toujours un cycle qui
est court qui se tient entre 5 et 7
jours quel que soit le département quel
que soit l'action de la police quel que
soi les les caractéristique générale en
fait il y a une propriété de l'émeute
c'est qu'en fait il y a une les gens
vont se rassembler ila des incidents qui
vont faire on va dire dégénérer
l'affrontement et il va y avoir un pic
et en fait ce pic il va assez vite
retomber euh probablement parce que
c'est fatiguant en fait comme activité
c'estàd que quand vous détruisez toutes
les nuits des voitures que vous courez
pour envoyer des cocktails incendiaires
sur le commissariat de police mais au
bout d'un moment vous êtes fatigué donc
il y a un phénomène d'épuisement qui un
phénomène qu'on va retrouver dans dans
tous les pays et nous on a ce cycle là
et et ce cycle on va le retrouver euh
hop je vais montrer ici mais faut que j'
un peu plus bas en euh 2023 en fait là
j'ai j'ai refait à partir des données
qui sont publiques he de la presse qui
avait été diffusé par le monde j'ai
refait les les cycles et en fait on voit
qu'on a exactement le même il faud
regarder que le trait qui est en
pointillé en fait qui est la moyenne
pour un département donc là j'ai pris
quelqu quelquesuns des des départements
et on voit en fait que la structure en
fait hmetière elle est toujours la même
et que la durée est toujours la même
tout se tient dans un intervalle de 5 à
7 jours donc c'est toujours là c'est
c'est comme je sais pas il y aurait une
une rythme une contamination par un
virus je pense par exemple au covid et
donc on sait bah les médecins savent que
la durée pendant laquelle on est
infectieux c'est de temps pendant la
durée pendant laquelle on a de la
température c'est de temps et cetera
donc on retrouve les mêmes systèmes de
de
régularité si je fais marcharie au pas
en 2005 comme on a pu analyser les
données ce qui est pas encore le cas en
2023 en tout cas à ma connaissance euh
les éme de 2005 les données ont été
réanalysés ici par des chercheurs
canadiens et ce qu'on ce qu'on voit
c'est que les mesures exceptionnelles
prises par le gouvernement à l'époque et
notamment l'état d'urgence ont pas eu
d'effet sur la dynamique temporelle
c'està-dire qu'une fois que c'est parti
ça brûle toujours de la même manière
avec le le mouvement que je viens juste
de de présenter et en revanche ce qu'on
voit aussi c'est que postérieurement au
phénomène d'émeutes il y a de manière
durable une élévation de la délinquence
c'estàdire que les territoires qui sont
particulièrement touchés par les par les
phénomènes émetiers ils deviennent plus
délinquants qu'ils ne l'était avant les
phénomènes
d'meutes donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que c'est sont des phénomènes qui
intéressent les pouvoirs publics parce
qu'ils ont des coûts économiques
astronomiques et ils ont des coûts de
long terme sur et des effets de long
terme sur la sécurité des des
citoyens et je voudrais rappeler alors
en matière maintenant de de de
déclenchement euh que les plus grandes
émeutes qu'on est enregistré dans les
pays occidentaux sont associés avec des
brutalités policières avec des des
actions de police agressif comme à
l'époque margarette Sacher en en
Grande-Bretagne ou bien avec des décès
au cours des opérations de police là
j'ai fait la liste parce que les
principaux encore une fois c'est c'est
le Royaume-Uni la France mais j'ai
rajouté aussi parce que c'est le cas le
le Canada et le Québec particulièrement
à Montréal en 2008 athè aussi en 2008 et
à chaque fois on retrouve le même
phénomène donc il y a une régularité et
nous on a enfin les les je suis plus
politiste que sociologue mais on a une
croyance dans le fait que bah les
régularités nous disent quelque chose
des liens de causalité je parle pas de
causalité directe parce que c'est plus
compliqué que ça mais en tout cas c'est
vrai que les brutalités policières sont
un déclencheur et encore une fois c'est
pas lié au système politique on n'est
pas le système grec on n'est pas et
cetera il y a il y a un phénomène qui
est qui est lié à la fonction symbolique
que la police remplit dans une société
c'est que quand une une organisation qui
a pour fonction la sécurité arrive à
dans des situations où elle va tuer une
personne la plupart du temps ou la
brutaliser désarmé et qu'on va avoir des
preuves vidéos de ces événements il va y
avoir un choc moral qui va entraîner une
mobilisation qui lui-même va entraîner
qui elle-même va entraîner d'autres
choses alors on a regardé je vous ai dit
la plupart des émeutes sont des les
émeutes minuscules en tout cas pas
imperceptibles puisqu'on peut les
enregistrer mais en fait sont des
variations dans la quantité des
destructions et des dégradation et on
est en train d'analyser les données
depuis 96 jusqu'en à 2002 en France avec
une petite équipe donc j'ai marqué les
noms des des collègues ici et ce qu'on
voit quand on quand on essaie de
comprendre si euh les décès au cours des
opérations de police euh déclenche ces
phénomènes d'émeutes est-ce qu'on voit
est- ce qu'on vérifie que c'est le cas
si la personne particulièrement si la
personne n'est pas armée c'est que si la
police tue quelqu'un qui n'est pas armée
et si la personne qui est tuée a un
prénom qui fait penser qu'elle a qu'elle
est d'origine étrangère et donc plus
souvent résident dans des quartiers
défavorisés ça c'est propice au
démarrage d'une émeute donc là ça c'est
la situation pour la France sur
euh sur une presque une trentaine
d'années donc on a vérifié empiriquement
que ce lien existait c'est pas
uniquement les très grandes émeutes qui
étaient lié à à l'action de la police
mais que les plus petites émeutes
étaient également lié à l'action de la
police
donc c'est je trouve c'est intéressant
parce que ça aide à comprendre qu'il y a
des variables structurelles au plan
socio-économique mais il y a aussi un
certain de variables structurelles qui
sont d'origine institutionnel qui sont
lié au fonctionnement normal des des
institutions avance encore un tout petit
peu le deuxème aspect donc qui est pas
le déclencheur direct qui est pas un
élément du déclenchement direct plutôt
mais qui est ce que j'ai appelé tout à
l'heure le phénomène de frustration il
est maintenant assez bien identifié
c'est la question des contrôles
d'identité répétitifs et des contrôles
d'identité discriminatoirees alors je je
pense que en bien peut-être en parlera s
s'il a envie d'en parler moi je vais
juste rappeler que on a fait une enquête
en 2016 dans dans les Bouches du rô et
on trouve que dès 12 ans euh les
contrôles d'identité euh qui touchent
donc les adolescents euh sont
particulièrement ciblés sur les
minorités et uniquement en zone police
pas en zone gendarmerie donc on a là des
éléments aussi qui disons qui sont de
nature à faire monter la température et
à faire que lorsqu'il va se produire un
accident ou un incident très grave en
fait c contrôle d'identité ils auront
fait s'élever la tel la température à un
tel niveau que bah
l'oxygène qui est dans l'air va
immédiatement
s'enflammer donc ça on a pas mal
d'éléments empiriques maintenant qui qui
montre ça et ce qu'on montrait des des
collègues allemands en analysant les
données de l'étude sociale européenne
qui est la grande étude qui est faite
dans tous les pays de l'UE qui veulent
bien la financer
euh ça c'est pour l'affaire Tho qui est
en ce moment devant un un tribunal et ce
qu'on voit en analysant laffire Tho
s'est produite au moment où était
réalisé l'enquête sociale européenne ce
qui fait que on peut regarder les
opinions des gens les jours qui
précèdent l'affaire TH et les jours qui
suivent l'affaire TH et ce que vous
voyez sur ce graphique c'est une
simplification de de de cette de de ces
résultats vous avez deux lignes une
ligne bleue et une ligne rouge et ce que
vous voyez c'est que la ligne bleue bah
elle est moins haute après euh le le le
fait que Tho était gravement blessé par
les trois policiers qu'avant c'estd que
dans la population générale ce type
d'événement réduit la confiance dans la
police et la ligne bleue c'est les
personnes qui n'ont pas d'origine
étrangère et la ligne rouge c'est les
personnes qui ont des origines
étrangères et ce phénomène de décru de
la confiance mais il est encore plus
fort dans les minorités c'estàd dans les
groupes qui vont s'identifier avec la
personne qui a été gravement blessé donc
voilà le le
petit petite petites choses que je
voulais dire et il y a un modèle qui est
qui a été proposé par un collègue
britannique qui s'appelle modèle flash
point modèle de l'éclair dans lequel il
dit bon il faut il faut combiner
différents événements pour comprendre le
déclenchement des des émeutes et en gros
je dirais il y a d'un côté des
événements qui tiennent à la
marginalisation
sociopolitique des individus ou des
territoires il y a deux phénomènes il y
a la concentration spatiale de la
pauvreté et les caractéristiques des
personnes le fait d'appartenir aux
minorités ethniqu c'est deux choses
différentes he le fait d'être blanc ou
noir et le fait d'habiter dans un
quartier où il y a beaucoup de blanc
noir ou beaucoup de pauvres c'est deux
choses différentes c'est il y a une
caractéristique structurale et une
caractéristique des individus en fait
c'est ces deux ensembles là aliment une
marginalisation sociop-politique et
elles vont se combiner avec les
tactiques policières qui peuvent les
gouvernements peuvent choisir de vouloir
développer des tactiques de police assez
agressives ça avait été le cas pour
Nicolas Sarkozi ça avait été le cas pour
Margaret Sacher dans les émeutes des
années 80 et ce qu'on voit en fait c'est
que la combinaison de ces deux
événements font que les incidents qui
vont se produire vont donner lieu à une
explosion voilà c'est c'est c'est ce
qu'on voit donc voilà j'ai rappelé ce ce
modèle qui est un modèle qui est assez
bien établi dans la littérature et qui a
été soumis à pas mal de tests empiriques
voilà je pense que ça
s'applique ça s'applique on avait les
données précises pour ce qui s'est passé
en 2023 si on pouvait accéder à ces à
ces informations je crois que ça
s'appliquerait pas mal à à elle voilà
merci de m'avoir écouté merci Monsieur
alors c'est Monsieur Marwan Mahamed ou
monsieur Fabien jaobard qui
continue je veux bien continuer si si
Maran il
souscrit et je me je me contenteraiis de
d'ajouter des notes en bot page au au
propos sing et et documentés auquel
j'adhère qui viennent d'être d'être
apporté je suis moi aussi donc comme
Sébastien rocher euh sociologue ou
politiste plus précisément et directeur
de recherche au CNRS euh j'ai travaillé
sur les questions de police de manière
quantitative ou bien de manière
qualitative notamment en en suivant ou
participant à des équipages de de de
police euh dans des zone urbaine de la
grande périphérie parisienne euh en
observation en observant leurs leurs
actions mais j'ai aussi de même pris
part à des ce qu'on appelle des
observations participantes du côté de
jeunes de grande banlieu parisiennees
qui se disaient victime
de brutalité et de d'abus d'autorité de
la part de la police et et et et j'ai pu
d'une certaine manière cette manière-là
acquérir des des sources venant si vous
voulez des deux côtés de euh la barrière
qui aujourd'hui semble séparer ces ces
deux groupes alors je vais me contenter
comme je vous le disais de
euh peut-être d'apporter quelques
éléments supplémentaires à ce que à ce
que vient de
dire Sébastien rocher
euh le premier élément concerne la
temporalité des émeutes euh
et je vais revenir sur les courbes de
euh les les les cycles et metiers que tu
as que tu as décrit euh en insistant sur
le fait que euh une différence majeure
entre ce que nous avons observé en 2005
et ce que nous avons observé en 2003
c'est que
euh en pardon en 2005 et en 2023 c'est
que en 2005 il y a eu en quelque sorte
deux euh déclencheur au cours d'un même
cycle d'événement le premier déclencheur
est la mort des deux mineurs dans le
transformateur électrique un jeudi soir
et le second événement déclencheur est
le lancé d'une grenade lacrimogène dans
un lieu de prière à clichis sous-bois
c'est ce lancé de Grenade lacrimogène
qui
a été pour reprendre la dernière diapo
de de de Sébastien rocher l'événement
déclencheur de fl point de la diffusion
nationale des émeutes euh
la singularité la particularité des ém
de 2023 à cet égard c'est le
déclenchement simultané
d'événements
violents dans un plus grand nombre de
villes distribué dans un plus grand
nombre de régions compris donc au sud de
la Loire et compris même plus précisment
dans les bouches d' r euh quelques
heures seulement après la diffusion de
la vidéo euh ça c'est un un un point qui
qui mérite d'être rappelé deuxième point
qui mérite d'être rappelé en ce qui
concerne la la comparaison des émeutes
2005 et des émeutes 2023 euh et
Sébastien rappelé que nous sommes tous
deux docteurs en sciences politiques
donc un petit peu
attentif à ce qui se joue sur la scène
politique les réactions des politiques
notamment les réactions
gouvernementales dans les premiers jours
les premières heures qui ont suivi les
événements 2005 euh et celles qui ont
suivi les événements en 2023 sont
radicalement différentes Nicolas Sarkozi
euh et un certain nombre de ses
conseillers parfois même d'ailleurs
contre d'autres membres du gouvernement
n'ont pas du tout joué l'apaisement dans
les jours qui ont suivi la mort des deux
enfants en 2005
euh pour un revenir sur ce qui a été dit
à l'époque euh mais le politique n'a pas
tempéré n'a pas eu à cœur en tout cas de
tempérer même si d'autres membres du
gouvernement euh défendaient une autre
ligne à commencé par Monsieur Bégag
ministre de des villes sans doute en
2023 vous vous souvenez sans doute que
il y a eu unanimité à la fois d'ailleurs
dans la représentation parlementaire et
au gouvernement pour condamner le geste
policier euh c'est important de le
souligner parce que ça n'a eu aucun
effet sur euh les euh comportements euh
que nous avons observé ça souligne à
quel point il y a une fraction de la
jeunesse qui euh
est particulièrement
sensible aux
actions des forces de l'ordre là aussi
il y a un police nationale jendarmerie
nationale police municipale hein c'est
important
euh et qui n'est pas du tout sensible à
ce qui peut être dit par les
représentants politiques
euh
c'est pour moi c'est un un phénomène qui
signe je dirais la distance
considérable qui sépare qui sépare ces
deux mondes
euh 3è 3è
point sur la géographie européenne des
émeutes
euh Sébastien à juste titre a évoqué les
disons de dimension nationale c'estd
celle qui se diffuse on va dire dans
dans dans dans plusieurs communes
simultanément en gros euh mais si on
prend l'ensemble des pays
ouest européens qui ont été touchés par
des phénomènes hmetiers ces 20 dernières
années on remarque qu'il s'agit de la
France de la Grande-Bretagne de la
Belgique des Pays Bas autrement dit euh
de pays post-coloniaux c'est-à-dire dont
les populations présentes sur dont une
partie de la population présente sur
leur sol sont issu des anciennes
colonies une exception à cela la Suède
qui connaît des phénomènes metiers
depuis une quinzaine d'années et qui
n'est pas du tout concerné par ENF de
loin en loin seulement enfin qui n'a pas
eu de territoire coloniaux c'est
important de considérer également cette
dimension là du problème parce que c'est
une dimension qui contribue très
vraisemblablement à la politisation
des et à une politisation
pour employer un terme plus courant
aujourd'hui à la radicalité de
l'expression politique euh des jeunes
dont nous parlons dans dans ces
pays 4e 4e point j'en reste au aux
jeunes en question pour essayer
d'apporter des éléments de de cadrage
dans la discussion parce que jeen
reprends un point que que que Sébastien
Rocher a indiqué en fait on sait peu de
choses sur les éuts de 2023 parce que
euh nous avons très peu de recherches
même les
recherches vous avez auditionné Antoine
jardin il me semble donc qui vous a
apporter quelques éléments quantitatifs
hein mais ce sont ce sont des éléments
qui sont qui méritent évidemment d'être
d'être entendus et pris en compte sont
des éléments encore fragiles parce que
bien sûr la variable à expliquer
c'est-à-dire émeute
elle n'est pas
donnée c'est pas on va pas c'est pas
comme mtéo France supérieur ou inférieur
à 0 ou à
15°gr ce qu'est une émeu ici ne l'est
pas là-bas il est clair que pour un
certain nombre de communes de sa
saintenis on peut très facilement
dissimuler tout un ensemble de feux de
poubelle ou de véhicules alors que dans
une ville du Loiret euh on ne on le peut
beaucoup plus difficilement parce qu'il
y a de la presse régionale et puis parce
qu'il y a un intérêt aussi à faire
valoir le fait que et ben telle ville
est à l'écart de euh
de brigades territoriales de de
gendarmerie de forces de l'ordre disponi
ou que le Commissariat a
été le commissariat de la ville manque
d'effectif et cetera donc
c'eston et puis par après par ailleurs
la presse régionale est de toute façon
attentive à des phénomènes qui
apparaissent là-bas comme comme
exceptionnel et donc la géographie des
émeutes elle reste encore
elle reste
encore relativement certaine même si on
sait que
euh le euh les émeutes ont touché en
priorité euh les euh grandes villes en
tout cas les villes de plus de 50000
habitants euh avec pour la plupart
d'entre elles
euh des euh quartiers politiques de la
ville donc ce sont des villes qui ont
des quartiers pauvres puisque les qpv
sont des euh euh désormais des critères
à la différence de ceux qui les ont quis
ont précédés euh des critères fondés
exclusivement sur sur le revenu
euh j'en reviens donc à à aux
populations qui ont pris part aux
émeutes il y a un gros enjeu qui
consiste à savoir qui sont les émeutiers
euh quelles sont les populations très
exactement qui ont pris part qui ont
pris part aux émeutes
euh alors euh ce que l'on sait c'est que
ce sont généralement des populations
jeunes masculines et urbaines bon mais
une fois qu'on a dit ça euh nous avons
quelques quelques sources de
d'information les rapports le rapport
IgA igj dont vous avez euvant bien sûr
qui a l'immense défaut hein il faut
quand même toujours le rappeler de ne
porter que sur les personnes qui se sont
fait interpeller vous avez interrogé les
policiers ils vous s doute ils vous ont
sans doute dit que il y a un certain
Delta un certain écart entre la
composition de la population interpellé
et la composition des participants les
plus actifs aux émeutes qui qui sans
doute anticipe dans les moyens qu'il
mettent en œuvre dans les émeutes par
exemple les tirs de de fusée les tirs de
mortiers la possibilité d'être
interpellé alors que le pillard
opportuniste anticipe beaucoup moins
facilement ce ce ce ce risque là donc
voilà une distorsion entre la population
interpellée la population
etmetière il n'empêche que moi j'ai
retenu deux donné très important enfin
majeur dans dans dans ces dossiers
dépouillés par l'Inspection générale de
la justice euh la part très importante
de de majeurs non diplômés sortis de du
système scolaire sans diplôme 30 % deux
fois supérieure à celle que l'on trouve
en population générale et parmi la
proportion des des personnes des euh des
personnes donc interpellées et diplômé
40 % sont diplômés euh
son titulaire d'un diplôme inférieur au
baccalauréat cap be brevet des collèges
et donc nous sommes sur des populations
qui sont à la marge à la marge de notre
société de ce point de vue si j'en crois
les premières analyses notamment des des
toutes premières analyses je dirais on
appellerait ça vraiment des analyses
exploratoires chez nous des préanalyses
il semble que et j'ai lu ça sous la
plume de HUG Lagrange qui
avait monté tout un un ensemble de de
corrélations territoriales pour
euh pour décrire le profil des ametiers
il semble que les variables sociales euh
diplôme catégorie de revenus du
territoire
euh l'emporte cette fois sur les
variables migratoires au sens où la
proportion de d'immigrés sur les
territoires ne semble pas corrélé avec
euh le la variable diichotomique émeute
oui etmeute non tout ça est assez
fragile ça méritera d'être d'être
approfondi mais il est clair qu'à un
moment on on touche à des questions qui
sont qui peuvent pas tellement être
saisis par la statistique et j'en
reviens là à la question des contrôles
d'identité
euh vous savez que depuis les années 80
et donc ça fait deux générations euh
depuis les années 80 pour être précis la
société française on va dire pour poser
des des des repères un peu temporels la
société française en quelque sorte elle
se saisit du problème de l'inséc de
l'insécurité à la fin des années 70
c'est le rapport perfit réponse à
l'insécurité 1977 1981 loi sécurité et
liberté qui
d'ailleurs consacre les contrôles
d'identité 1983 marche pour l'égalité
une marche entreprise par les enfants de
l'immigration
on a donc en France 45 ans de de
problèmes urbains de rapport avec la
police
de de
problèmes liés à
une jeunesse urbaine ou périphérique
et au fil du
temps c'est cette jeunesse
là n'est pas évidemment par la
statistique officielle mais commence à
faire corps
à former un groupe social pour reprendre
le terme de Sébastien je m'explique
j'avais fait moi aussi une enquête sur
les contrôles d'identité à Paris on
avait fait suivre des policiers sans
qu'ils son rendre compte
pour collecter les variables qui
caractérisent les personnes qui le
contrôlent à Paris Gard du Nord châelet
dans 5 endroits différents et puis on
avait comparé avec la population qui est
présente sur ces lieux-là et et on
s'était rendu compte que dans les lieux
où les personnes blanches sont
minoritaires
elles sont sous-crôlé sous-crôlé par
rapport à leur part dans la population
disponible dans les lieux où les
personnes blanches sont très
majoritaires elles sont également sous-c
contrôlées autrement dit euh la
probabilité d'être contrôlé ne dépend
pas du tout de
la nature de la composition de la
population disponible et de la couleur
de peau des individus il faut ajouter à
ça que la couleur de peau n'est pas le
seul critère qui déclenche qui est
associé au
contrôle l'âge le sex et l'accoutrement
vestimentaire quand vous cumulez quatre
variables qui sont jeunes hommes non
blanc habillé de manière typiquement
jeune et en particulier on avait
identifié jogging casquette
basket casquet ou capuche bref
Couvrechef typiquement jeune pour le
dire
ainsi là vous avez un risque d'être
contrôlé qui est démesuré par rapport à
celui des populations
autres au au bout de 40 ans lorsque vous
avez un acte de des de la puissance des
pouvoirs publics des forces de l'ordre
qui s'adressent systématiquement aux
mêmes populations que ces populations
par les émeutes mais aussi par leur rap
par tout un ensemble de choses décrivent
ces phénomènes décrivent également ce
qu'elles perçoivent comme étant une non
réponse à ces phénomènes vous créez là
un ce qu'on appelle un sentiment
d'appartenance une population qui va
être invisible dans la statistique
publique mais qui va avoir une réalité
substantielle et cette population
c'est-à-dire une population de jeunes
urbains surexposés à la tension
policière c'est celle-ci qui est
évidemment au cœur des émeutes et j'en
finit avec deux
points sur lesquels je voudrais
également attirer votre attention le
premier point c'est la réponse des
pouvoirs publics j'ai évoqué la réponse
des pouvoirs publics dans les heures ou
les jours qui ont suivi le l'événement
déclencheur de l'émeut la mort de Naël
marzou à Nanterre la réponse des
pouvoirs publics dans les mois qui ont
suivi les meutes euh m'a paraît tout à
fait
singulière lorsqu'il y a eu une grande
vague d'émeutes urbaines au milieu des
années 60 aux États-Unis le président
Johnson a réuni une très vaste
commission la commission carner du nom
de son président et la Commission kner a
posé le fait que dans l'écrasante
majorité des cas les émeutes étaient d
au à l'abus de force par les par les
policiers et le président Johnson
commission Kerner commission katsenbach
ensuite a considéré que l'organisation
policière était un problème qu'il
fallait la il fallait faire quelque
chose ça a donné lieu à des centaines de
millions d'euros déversé dans les
universités et les centres de recherche
pour essayer de travailler à
l'amélioration de la police ça a donné
lieu à des à des programmes de problem
solving policing community policing ce
qu'on appelle police de proximité chez
nous on a tenté de réformer la police
estce qu'on a réussi est-ce qu'on a
échoué c'est une autre question mais en
tout cas la police les actions
policières ont été une politique
publique ont été considéré comme un
problème public si vous écoutez la
réaction du gouvernement fin septembre
début octobre et bien euh la police
n'était plus sur
l'agenda n'était plus du tout sur
l'agenda pas même l'article
l435-1 du code de la sécurité intérieure
qu'on pourrait sous réserve de ce qu'en
diront les juges qu'on pourrait estimer
comme étant associé ou déclencheur même
du tir policier
euh la politique de la ville a été mise
à l'index elle a échoué euh les
structures parentales ont été mises à
l'index elles échouent euh l'école
l'autorité la crise de l'autorité que
sais-je mais la police a disparu de
l'agenda c'est d'une certaine manière
c'est normal parce que dans le même
temps puisque l'émeute a été la réponse
première ou la réponse majeure apportée
à l'événement et bien bien sûr la police
a été restaurée dans son rôle les forces
de l'ordre ont été restauré dans leur
rôle de euh réétablissement de l'ordre
et du coup la critique de la police euh
euh enfin ce geste là a rendu d'autant
plus difficile la critique de la police
par le gouvernement et par le politique
mais ça renforce bien sûr ce sentiment
auprès d'une auprès de cette population
particulière que décidément les pouvoirs
publics ne traitent pas la question qui
les concerne et qui est la question qui
les a amené dans la rue euh dans la rue
euh dans les rues euh fin juin début
juillet euh deuxème point lié à cet
aspect là et j'en aurais terminé
euh j'ai beaucoup parlé des des des des
émeutiers je voudrais revenir quand même
sur émeut émeut c'est très compliqué
c'est pas une qualification pénale au
moins destruction dégradation trafic de
stupéfiant
euh atteinte à l'intégrité physique sont
des qualifications pénales mais émeut
bon on décrit plein de choses il est
clair qu'il y a eu deux modus opérandi
son dans la plupart des cas sans doute
consécutifs l'un à l'autre un
successif les pillages ensuite et
d'abord les affrontements à l'autorité
au symboles de l'État mais quand on
compare les bâtiments publics qui ont
été pris pour cible en 2005 et ceux qui
ont été pris pour cible en
2023 il semble que sous réserve
d'analyse vraiment plus fine mais il
semble que les écolle les bibliothèques
à la différence de 2005 euh et été
beaucoup plus épargné et que les cibles
se sont concentrées et de manière
beaucoup plus violente et beaucoup plus
équipée avec les mortiers hein qui
semble-t-il avait été stocké en
prévision du 14 juillet
euh phénomène qu'on conna qu'on connaît
bien en Alsace mais aussi en en
Allemagne
euh ce sont essentiellement les
bâtiments de police nationale
gendarmerie nationale police municipale
qui ont été pris pour cible et donc on
voit bien que si vous voulez à un moment
euh je suis pas d'accord avec
l'appréciation qu'il y a dans le rapport
IgA igj sur la mort de naë N n'est
évoqué par je sais plus combien il y a
un pourcentage inférieur ind 10 là qui
qui qui est mentionné dans le rapport à
partir des auditions des PV d'audition
d'interrogatoire policier bon les cibles
des hémetiers nous renseignent
suffisamment je pense sur les leur
motivations et il est clair que euh on
est ici dans dans dans dans on est ici
face à un phénomène
où en effet aujourd'hui en France une
fraction de la population et c'est une
population urbaine c'est une population
masculine c'est une population qui est
issue des des des des populations
principalement coloniales euh son
rapport à la politique et c'est ça qui
doit à mon avis retenir l'attention
c'est d'abord un rapport à la police et
un rapport au aux abus policiers et donc
cette question là traité du rapport
entre
police et société est à mon avis une des
questions essentielles si on veut bien
sûr
limiter le ce type d'événement la
survenue de ce type d'événement à
l'avenir je vous
remercie merci Monsieur alors la parole
est à Monsieur Marwan Mohamed vous avez
la
parole je vous merci beaucoup
euh alors il y a beaucoup de choses qui
ont été qui ont été dites moi je vais
développer une autre perspective mais
commencer par vous dire que en arrivant
au Sénat j'ai traversé la rue Monsieur
le Prince qui est à deux pas d'ici et et
la rue Monsieur le Prince c'est la rue
où a été assassiné malikousekin et après
la mort de Malik
kousekin euh il y avait eu de des
grandes manifestations conventionnelles
pour la plupart euh pour dénoncer les
les les violences et et les brutalités
qui ont abouti à à son à son à son à son
décès c'était dans les années 80 on est
dans les années 2020 aujourd'hui dans
une mission d'information en train de se
poser des questions sur les raisons qui
ont amené à cette à ce niveau
d'intensité inédie sur une période
courte qu'on a pu observer fin juin fin
juin oui à la fin du mois de juin je je
pense que l'une des réponses est
peut-être dans ce parallèle faire avec
avec le destin tragique de Malik
kousekin c'est que c'est que c'est une
question qui n'a pas
été affronté de face par le par le par
le politique et en particulier le point
commun entre la mort de Malik kousekin
et celle de Na marzou que le point
commun entre les deux périodes c'est le
profil racial des victimes pas forcément
le profil social mais c étudiant le
profil racial des des deux victimes et
également le fait que ceux qui leur ont
les personnes qui les ont tué ce sont
des des des des policiers donc moi aussi
en arrivant je réfléchissais à à la
question de la réponse gouvernementale
aux émeutes de joint une réponse qui
arriva extrêmement rapidement et qui ne
mentionnait
pas d'aucune manière que ce soit une
réforme ou une réflexion ou une une
volonté de changement des manières de
faire de la police dans dans dans ce
pays
euh mon point de vue euh alors j'ai
commencé sans me présenter je vais le
faire maintenant je suis chargé de
recherche au CNRS veillez m'excuser au
centre Maurice alvx et moi je travaille
plus non pas sur sur la police et son
fonctionnement mais je travaille sur sur
la rue et son fonctionnement à travers
les les phénomènes de bande de jeunes le
trafic de stupéfiants le grand
banditisme ce sont les sujets qui
m'intéressent et j'ai été amené à
observer et à interroger des personnes
impliquées dans ces dans ces dans ces
émeux dans ces révoltes euh notamment en
2005 parce que c'était la période durant
laquelle je faisais ma thèse de doctorat
euh et c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
refaire après euh ce qui s'est passé en
2023 euh c'est euh de retourner euh sur
les terrain et d'interroger deux types
d'acteurs euh en premier lieu tous les
acteurs de l'éducation populaire de
l'intervention sociale tous les acteurs
de terrain acteurs jeunesse acteurs de
la médiation de la Prévention
Spécialisée c'est-à-dire tous les
acteurs qui sont euh euh en proximité
quotidienne et régulière avec euh une
partie et cette fraction des jeunes qui
s'est impliqué qui s'est engagé fin juin
de de début juillet mais également à
travers eux et à travers des des des
contact personnel j'ai discuté avec un
certain nombre euh de de ceux qui
s'étaient engagés dans ces émeutesl fin
juin dans un certain nombre de villes
euh uniquement situé en Île-de-France
pas pas en région euh tout ça est
extrêmement provisoire tout ça est
extrêmement précaire euh comme
construction de de de données et de de
connaissances donc ça va être des
réflexions qui sont des réflexions
provisoires mais qui se basent sur une
présence sur du long terme et sur une
proximité euh à très long terme de cette
fraction de la population dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure tout simplement
parce que la temporalité politique qui
fait que il y a une mission
d'information qui nous interroge
aujourd'hui n'est pas la temporalité
scientifique notamment euh dès lors
qu'on veut être dans une approche un peu
plus qualitative voire ethnographique
euh pour assimiler des en tout cas
accumuler des des données alors mon
propos il sera plus sur la question des
ametiers eux-mêmes et sur les
rationalités qu'on leur prête dans le
discours public il vous a pas échappé
que les les les ce qu'on appelle les
émotiers sont des sujets parlés euh que
l'on commente sur lesquels on plaque
toute une forme de rationalité à travers
et par inférence en regardant les les
cibles les dégradations et cetera et
c'est moins des sujets parlés
c'est-à-dire des personnes on va
attendre le micro pour essayer de
comprendre comment est-ce qu'ils vivent
euh ces ces ces rivalités en ces
rivalités pardon là je fais un
déplacement avec un autre sujet de
recherche euh C c'est ces émeutes là
c'est bien la parenthèse avec les
rivalités c'est c'est c'est un un lapsus
qui qui qui peut être salutire parce que
l'un des aspects assez intéressants
c'est que dans des territoiresù on a des
rivalités entre bandes et entre
quartiers euh c'est des rivalités qui
ont été mises entre parenthèses euh
pendant les les les les les émeutes avec
des accords tacites entre jeunes de
différents territoires qui se sont dit
bon pour l'instant on va arrêter de se
faire la guerre entre nous on va se
concentrer sur l'affrontement avec les
les les forces de l'ordre ou un certain
nombre de de de représentants de l'État
je ferme cette petite parenthèse là mais
elle est pas sans lien avec la manière
dont ils peuvent le le le vivre euh je
peux tirer de mes recherches mais
également de la lecture d'un certain
nombre de de de travaux
euh le constat que au fond la la
l'engagement de dans dans les émeutes ou
en tout cas le fonctionnement des
émeutes repose sur quatre types de
rationalité euh qu'on retrouve dans dans
les dans les engagements émetiers quatre
types de rationalité qu'on peut
retrouver y compris chez une même
personne engagé dans dans les rivalités
enfin voilà ça revient dans les dans les
rivalités avec l'État peut-être euh dans
ces dans ces dans ces dans ces émeutes
euh et au fond c'est des phénomènes les
émeutes révoltent et vous verrez
pourquoi j'hésite entre les deux mots
euh c'est des phénomènes qui sont des
phénomènes
hybrides des phénomènes hybrides euh et
la première rationalité qui semble
absolument essentielle celle dont parle
Sébastien rocher celle dont parle
principalement Fabien Fabien jaobard
c'est au fond la dynamique de révolte
c'est d'abord ces phénomènes là sont
d'abord alimentés par une dynamique de
révolte le choc Mora le sentiment
d'adignation qui repose sur un sentiment
d'injustice tout ce qu' a présenté
Sébastien Rochet tout à l'heure sur les
les motivations et et les les logiques
de de marrage du de de de ces révoltes
je les partage euh c'est quand même la
locomotive la le sentiment de révolteé
c'est la locomotive de de ces de ces
émeutes on n jamais vu d'émeutes
nationales qui démarraent par autre
chose que par ce type
d'incident euh en tout cas avec ce
public là donc ça c'est le premier point
euh ça veut dire que derrière ça on a un
contentieux politique euh qui concerne
davantage les les personnes qui sont le
plus confrontées euh aux interactions
avec la police il est pas irrationnel au
contraire c'est tout à fait normal et
rationnel
que les jeunes issus des minorités ou
issus d'immigration se sentent davantage
concernés ils sont davantage
contrôlé c'est c'est une exposition à
ces formes de de de de de contrôle
répété de contrô d'identité de brutalité
de tutoiement et cetera euh qu'il est
euh qu'il est qu'il est concerne d'abord
eux comme Fabien et son équipe l'ont
montré notamment ceux qui sont habillés
d'une certaine manière et qui sont
plutôt qui sont plutôt
jeunes donc ça c'est le premier point
mais j'aimerais bien qu'on ne pas qu'on
limite pas ce sentiment d'injustice de
le réduire à la question des
interactions avec la police c'est-à-dire
que quand on leur tend le micro il parle
des interactions avec la police mais
c'est un peu le déclencheur d'un
sentiment de de de d'indignation de
sentiment de G d'injustice qui se
nourrit plus globalement par le climat
politique par les discours publs à leur
égard à l'égard de leurs parents parfois
par le traitement de certaines
institutions à l'égard de de de leur de
leur proches donc c'est tout ça qui est
qui est important à à à à noter et à
souligner la deuxième logique qui n'est
pas contradictoire avec la la la la
première c'est que les rival enfin les
les les révoltes ces révoltesl sont ont
aussi une dimension ludique ont aussi
une dimension ludique qui est présente
c'est-à-dire que la révolte la colère
l'indignation ces mobilisations
n'empêche pas de rendre l'exercice
ludique alimenté par des formes
d'excitation de compétition horifique
d'adrénaline de de de de d'alimenter une
forme de sentiment d'exister à travers
l'engagement dans les rival dans dans
les dans les dans les dans les émeutes
et dans les révoltes et tout ça est
amplifié par ce que permettent les
outils numériques aujourd'hui
euh et euh ce qui m'a quand même frappé
les outils numériques permettent de
viraliser de diffuser euh et d'accéder à
des formes de gratification assez
importantes tout en manifestant sa
colère les choses ne sont pas à à
opposer en fait c'est pas soit l'un soit
l'autre ça peut être l'un et l'autre si
on veut vraiment comprendre les les
formes d'engagement moi j'ai été frappé
par la multiplication notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux sur snapchat sur TikTok
ou d' autres vecteurs euh numérique
comme cela j'ai été frappé par le nombre
de de fausses vidéos par exemple c'estàd
des jeunes qui ont pris qui ont chopé
des vidéos sur internet des des vidéos
qui sont spectaculaires et qui ont
accollé pendant C période là le nom de
leur quartier ou le nom de leur ville
donc on a vu des vidéos lié avec des
espèces de de de pseudo tireur d'élite
sur un toit quelqu'un avec un bazooka
des armes de guerre mais des armes
lourdes euh des vidéos extrêmement
spectaculaires et puis une petite
vérification permettait de se rendre
compte que c'était les vidéos qui
avaient été chopées en Syrie euh pendant
la guerre civile de choper euh en
Amérique latine et cetera et et cette
démarche là montre bien à quel point la
compétition honorifique et quelque chose
qui s'est quand même greffé euh euh à
cette à ce qui s'est passé fin juin
début juillet 3ème rationalité c'est une
rationalité qui est économique une
rationalité qui est économique avec des
possibilités de consommation euh qui
sont ouvertes par par par ces événements
alors on a parlé de pillage mais il faut
regarder dans le détail de de quoi on
parle les pillages c'est surtout des
biens de consommation valorisable
immédiatement téléphone utilisable
parfum vêtements c'est-à-dire tous les
biens de consommation qui sont le plus
recherchés et c'est mais ça a été
également les pillag du lait des couches
des pâtes du riz euh ce qui dit quelque
chose également du niveau de vie et du
et de et de la question sociale qui est
indissociable de ce qui vient de se
passer qu'est-ce que ça veut dire de
profiter du pillage du Lidl du coin pour
aller récupérer des biens de
consommation qui sont des biens courants
euh et quand je dis rationalité
économique c'est-à-dire que ça peut être
également pour certains le fait de
Siller une caméra de vidéosurveillance
et de la faire tomber de l'abîmer voilà
pour d'autres pour d'autres raisons et
enfin la 4e rationalité ce que
permettent c'est c'est ces émeutes ces
événements euh c'est le le règlement de
contentieux le règlement de contentieux
euh alors sur la rationalité économique
il y a aussi les opportunités qui sont
ouvertes je me rappelle en 2005 on avait
beaucoup parlé et c'était la police
c'était la police judiciaire de Lille je
crois où la direction départementale de
la sécurité publique de Lille qui avait
estimé à à peu près alors je sais pas si
mes chiffres sont précis mais à peu près
un/ers des des véhicules brûlés comme
étant des arnaques aux
assurances voilà typiquement on au
compte des véhicules brûlés on va les
associer aux manifestations de de de de
colère et derrière il y a des gens qui
profitent euh de de du mouvement de
l'émeut pour pouvoir récupérer une prime
d'assurance euh et enfin la question du
règlement des contentieux euh je pense
que c'est c'est c'est ce qui s'est passé
fin juin c'est queon n' jamais eu alors
faudra vérifier autant par exemple
d'élus de maires qui ont été attaqué euh
localement de représentants du du
pouvoir économique local y compris des
des figures du travail social
d'institutions qui ont été visées et
cell d'à côté qui a pas été visé il y a
une rationalité dans les commerces qui
sont broulés ceux qui sont préservés il
y a une rationalité dans les dans les
dans les institutions qui sont touchées
et ceux qui sont préservés il y a pas
une rationnalité tout le temps il y a
pas une rationalité tout le temps euh
mais je pense que c'est un point qui
quand on a une approche ethnographique
qui est un point important pour
comprendre finalement les mécanismes qui
sont observables alors le fait de mettre
en avant ces quatre rationalités cette
le caractère très hybride de ces
révoltes euh euh ne ne ne doit pas
occulter le fait que la dynamique de
révolte et la locomotive et reste et
demeure la locomotive c'est dire que le
ce qui se les opportunités qui s'ouvrent
dès lors que une émeute se nationalise
et perdure pendant plusieurs jours les
opportunités qui s'ouvrent sont relèv
davantage de l'opportunisme lié aux
révoltes plus
que
de de de des motivations principales de
ces de ces révoltes
alors pour conclure
euh et peut-être sûrement avoir des
échanges des échanges
derrière je reviendrai un peu sur la
question que j'ai soulevé en en en en
introduction l'intensité qu'on a observé
en en fin juin renvoie pour moi une
forme de surenchère c'estàdire
surenchère c'estàdire que on est passé
de 2005 à 2023 c'est aussi un message
qui a envoyé l'intensité qui est envoyé
c'est un message politique en soi et si
je regarde les données publiées par le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour comparer
que j'ai comparé avec le 2023 il y a eu
10 fois plus de bâtiments publics
endommagésen 2005 en 2023 2005 il y a eu
davantage de véhicules incendiés il y a
eu quatre fois plus de policiers et
gendarmes mobilisés euh il y a eu quatre
fois plus de de policiers gendarmes
blessés c'est qu'en terme d'intensité ça
cette intensité ce niveau de de de de
violence cette détermination dans la
confrontation et j'ai même envie de dire
toutes ces innovations un peu tactiques
qu'on a pu observer sur le terrain c'est
qu'il y avait dans certaines villes les
gens étaient très bien organisés parfois
en cadré on parle des mortiers
d'artificees moi je sais de sources sûr
que un revend ur de contrebande de
manière informelle de revente illégale
de Mor d'artifice a offert à des jeunes
d'une autre ville son stock parce que il
partageit la colère qui était là l'heure
voyez donc c'est c'est juste pour dire
que on n pas fini de
d'étudier il nous faut du temps pour
creuser davantage ces c'est c'est c'est
ces questions là mais il me semble
absolument essentiel en tout cas
j'espère que la mission d'information
arrivera à cette conclusion
que la question des manières de faire de
et des pratiques policières sera remis
au cœur de l'agenda politique parce que
je vois pas comment sortir de cette
logique de
surenchère sans sans ça je vous remercie
de votre écoute merci Monsieur Merci
alors y a-t-il des
questions monsieur Durin madame madame
le stage brigau alors Monsieur Durin oui
merci messieur pour pour vos réflexions
et puis pour le l'exposé de ses travaux
euh je préside en ce moment pour le
Sénat là une une commission d'enquête
sur le narcotrafic euh la question du
narcotrafic a été évoqué aussi ça a été
un des commentaires fréquents alors dans
tous les sens hein euh c'est à cause des
trafiquants qui ont poussé au aux
émeutes c'it eux qui ont arrêté les
émeutes voilà donc dans dans ces
insertions diverses et variées et
parfois contradictoires est-ce que vous
avez déjà des éléments de d'analyse sur
ce
sujet madame
narassa oui merci pour vos présentations
euh
deux deux petites deux questions euh sur
cette r ce rapport à la police et la et
la réaction par rapport en 2023 alors on
on a beaucoup entendu dans les dans les
dans d'autres auditions auparavant que
il y a beaucoup des interpellés qui qui
mentionnaient très peu euh la question
de la mort de Naël et donc il y a une un
peu une supposition que il y a pas
nécessairement de revendication
politique éthique très construite parce
qu'il ne mentionne pas spécifiquement
euh la mort de Noël sauf un peu sur
l'île de France par rapport à ce que
vous dites là ça ça montre quand même
que parce que il y a une colère et un
sentiment d'injustice qui est construit
depuis longtemps même sil ne il ne le
verbalise pas il y a quand même une
motivation politique euh qui est assez
forte dans dans les éléments de
déclencheur je me demandais euh est-ce
que dans la mort de naë il y a pas aussi
une particularité parce qu'on a eu
d'autres euh jeunes malheureusement qui
ont été tué dans des refus d'obtempéré y
compris des jeunes issus de minorités
euh il y a eu cet élément particulier de
la vidéo euh et donc peut-être qu'il a
amplifié euh le ce sentiment euh d'une
de d'un d'une institution policière et
judiciaire prête à couvrir euh un un des
leur qui a possiblement malagi euh qui a
eu qui a utilisé enfin qui a fait un
abus de un abus de pouvoir et voilà et
euh euh euh et et et donc euh et et donc
qui a peut-être aussi euh est-ce que
enfin est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cet élément là particulier par
rapport à d'autres événements qu'on a
qu'on a pu avoir et qui peut expliquer
plus spécifiquement pourquoi il y a eu
des émeutes dans le casre de la mort de
Naël et peut-être pas dans d'autres dans
d'autres cas on a eu même plus récemment
encore he d'autres incidents avec des
policiers et on n' pas eu le genre le
même type de déclenchement euh et puis
et puis à la fois il y a je je sais que
vous avz pas parlé ici aujourd'hui mais
je sais que et Sébastien rocher et
Fabien jaobard vous avez vous avez aussi
travaillé sur cette question de de du
rapport à la police et du et du
euh du des méthodes délibérées
aujourd'hui de maintien de l'ordre qui
sont qui sont pas du tout dans la
désescalade et qui sont beaucoup plus
dans la
confrontation vis-à-vis des manifestants
euh et donc autant on on peut voir par
rapport effectivement à une population
très particulière aujourd'hui et qu'on
estime désocialisé et C qui sont ces
jeunes des quartiers euh et que à partir
de là on on voit la construction de d'un
rapport de confrontation avec la police
autant euh on voit aussi et et on nous a
dit dans d'autres dans d'autres
auditions que la carte euh des émeutes
en particulier hors î- de-fance se
recoupe assez clairement avec la carte
des des manifestations gilets jaunes et
on a eu aussi chez les gilets jaunes et
donc là on a pas du tout le même
historique de ces populations gilets
jaunes vis-à-vis de la police on a eu
aussi pas tous évidemment mais une
partie des gilets jaunes qui étaient
dans un rapport extrêmement
confrontationnel extrêmement violent
avec la police avec certains qui sont
montés à Paris avec des armes et cetera
avec une volonté de casser du flic et
donc est-ce que au-delà de cette
question des des quartiers et des et des
problèmes euh qui sont spécifiques au
disc à la la au discrimination et aux
inégalités persistantes euh dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville il y a
pas plus généralement euh une question
de justement de de de de de police et de
et de politique de maintien de l'ordre
qui qui incite finalement à une à une un
rapport de confrontation avec la police
plutôt qu'un rapport de
désescalade merci Madame madame sage
brigot merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement ça va pas étonner un
certain nombre de mes
collègues ici présent qu'il y a une
certaine forme de vos analyses à tous
les trois qui m'interrogent et qui
m'interpelle beaucoup surtout si on les
analyse que sur un volet violence
policière je pense pas qu'on avance
beaucoup si on part d'un principe que
systématiquement on vit dans un pays où
il y a des violences policières et
que l'origine de ce que nous avons vécu
c'est exclusivement les violences
policières je pense que si on ne part
que de son constat là on risque pas
d'avancer beaucoup pourquoi parce que
des violences euh il y en a partout
notre notre pays est surtout soumis à un
refu d'autorité puisqueaujourd'hui vous
l'avez souligné tout à l'heure des élus
sont attaqué les enseignants sont
menacés et tout forme d'autorité dans
notre pays est contesté donc je ne suis
pas sûr que de partir uniquement sur le
fait des violences policières que moi je
conteste bon donc mais j'ai le droit de
le faire ça explique tout dans notre
pays aujourd'hui et moi j'ai vécu en
tant qu'élu les les émeutes de 2005 et
les émeutes de 2023 c'est pas du tout la
même chose en terme d'explication en
terme de vécu et en terme de conséquence
voilà vous parliez tout à l'heure
monsieur Mohamad des mortiers les
mortiers ils ont commencé à installer
dans notre pays il y a quelques années
et la course au mortiers et la violence
des mortiers c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne connaissait pas je sais pas si vous
avez déjà assisté à des des des enfin
des une violence dans les cités avec les
mortiers c'est quelque chose d'effrayant
et la police effectivement est quand
même soumise à presque que des menaces
de mort j'ai envie de dire alors il y a
des choses il y a des sujets que vous
n'avez pas abordé ni l'un ni l'autre ni
les uns ni les autres c'est l'âge des
des de certains émeutiers pendant ces
émeutes c'est le rôle des parents la
place des parents je pense que c'est un
peu
compliqué de de ne pas aborder aussi ces
sujet là sans parler de la place des
parents parce que quand même les émeutes
elles ont lieu avec des enfants qui ont
tout cassé tout volé enfin tout épillé
dans leur propre cité ils sont pas allés
casser ailleurs ils ont brûlé les écoles
ils ont brûlé les bibliothèques de leur
quartiers donc les parents ont quand
même peut-être parfois vu des choses et
auraiit pu peut-être être un peu plus
acteur et il y a quelque chose d'
d'extrêmement nouveau aujourd'hui et
c'est une question que qu'il faut
aborder c'est qu'il y a quelque chose de
nouveau dans notre pays et au sein de
notre population parce que je les ai on
est un certain nombre d'élus avoir vécu
ça je pense qu'il y a quelque chose
qu'il faut acter et poser c'est que les
les habitants des quartiers qui ont subi
ces violences ces émeutes l'angoisse de
voir Laur voiture brûlée ne le
supportent plus et ça c'est nouveau
parce que les gens le disent ils ne le
supportent plus alors vous avez deux
phénomènes qu'il faut analyser puisque
vous analysez les choses en tant que
sociologue c'est les habitants des
quartiers qui sont terrés chez eux en
disant prvu que ma voiture ne soit pas
brûlée et on en a assez parce que
d'abord ça donne une image de notre
quartier extrêmement négative on a pas
envie parce qu'il y a aussi des gens qui
vivent calmement dans ce dans ces
quartiers et puis il y a une autre une
autre catégorie de la population qui dit
et c'est du vécu pour la première fois
j'ai entendu ça on en a marre de payer
pour ce qui cassent et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut entendre c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut entendre parce que
c'est très révélateur de ce que dans
notre pays ce qui se passe dans notre
pays il se passe des choses c'est que ce
pays va se cliver encore davantage et
que euh ceux qui payent et qui jusqu'à
présent payaient parce que c'est la
solidité et parce que c'est normal et
parce que quand on on a moins et bien
ceux qui ont plus donne et bien ceux qui
ont plus aujourd'hui ne veulent plus
donner et ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut absolument étudier parce que c'est
une vraie réalité dans toutes les villes
et dans tous les quartiers merci Madame
madame Linel monsieur kerouche et
Monsieur benaroche
oui merci monsieur le Président j'avais
prévu de de poser une question qui
finalement a été déjà posé auparavant
par Corina rassigin sur le la la
superposition des cartographies entre
celle des gilets jaunes et celle des
émeut de juin 2023 et le lien avec par
ailleurs une partie de l'analyse que
vous avez pu faire sur le profil on va
dire ça comme ça je crois que c'est le
terme que vous avez
utilisé de d'un certain nombre de de ces
jeunes qui sont bien souvent et trop
souvent contrôlés du fait de leur profil
par la police au-delà des incidents qui
ont pu
déclencher des des enfin des incidents
de la mort de Naël et ensuite des
indices des incidents qu'ont déclenché
les émeutes de 2023 comme Corine
rassigin a posé la question je n'en dis
pas davantage mais je voudrais néanmoins
garder la parole en particulier après ce
que ce que je viens d'entendre moi je je
suis sénatrice depuis quelques mois
seulement j'étais auparavant première
adjointe à Lille et dans ce que ce cadre
là il se trouve que je suis allée sur le
terrain le le soir du 24 du 25 du 26 J
hein comme comme d'autres élus locaux
pour essayer d'abord de comprendre ce
qui se passe dans la mesure du possible
dans une ville de 230000 habitants avec
6 quartiers sur 10 en politique de la
ville et des quartiers qui ne se
ressemblent pas tous voilà qui ont tous
des des indicateurs sociaux qui sont pas
très élevés mais ça ne veut pas dire que
ces quartiers se ressemblent des
quartiers qui ont avaient déjà connu des
émeutes en 2005 et moi je ne crois pas
que ce soit nouveau qu'un certain nombre
des habitants de ces quartiers disent
qu'ils n'ont pas envie qu'on touche à
leurs équipements à leurs écoles c'est
des choses qu'on a déjà entendu en 2005
qu'on a retrouvé en 2023 et en ce qui
concerne ma ville la différence entre
2005 et 2023 c'est que la rénovation
urbaine est passer par là et que dans
l'ensemble un nombre de ces quartiers en
tout cas du point de vue urbain
bâtimentaire d'espace public vivent
mieux ça veut pas dire que ça va
forcément mieux au point de vue social
ou ou ou du point de vue du chômage
voilà donc moi je voulais simplement
témoigner également euh que que j'étais
euh ce soir-là dans la rue que j'ai vu
unensomble de personnes qui n'étaient
pas toutes les mêmes qui n'étaient pas
toutes jeunes qui manifestement
n'avaient pas toutes les mêmes
revendications qui parfois n'en avait
pas du tout je ne suis les les il se
trouve qu'un C nombre d'auteurs ont été
arrêtés depuis ils ne sont pas tous du
quartier dans lequel ils ont pu brûler
on a eu une école on a eu une mairie de
quartier qui venait d'être rénovée
l'école aussi venait d'être rénové on a
eu un hôtel de police municipale qui
venait d'ouvrir bon c'était pas que des
gens qui habitaient aux alentours moi
très franchement j'aborde cette question
et c'est pour ça que je suis là pour
vous écouter avec beaucoup d'humilité et
de modestie à ce jour et après avoir
encore une fois échangé y compris
localement avoir suivi un certain nombre
d'auditions ici et vous avoir écouté moi
je n'ai encore pas d'enseignement
particulier à attirer euh de tout cela
et je voulais le dire ici parce que je
trouve que voilà c'est des sujets
suffisamment graves et sensibles pour
qu'on n tire pas
forcément des conclusions parfois un peu
hatives et qu'en tout cas je ne suis pas
sûr de partager merci d'où l'intérêt de
notre mission chers collègues Monsieur
kerouche Merci monsieur le le Président
je crois pas que donner ou essayer de
donner des explications sociologique
comme vous l'avez fait c'est forcément
trouver des excuses c'est simplement
essayer de mettre juste en exerg ce qui
peut expliquer les difficultés qui sont
celles de de notre pays qu'il faut pas
nier et qui sont reflété notamment par
par ces émeutes ce qui est clair c'est
que vous avez fait le parallèle avec
avec Malik ousekin c'est que à 40 ans
d'écart on se rend compte que notre pays
a toujours un problème avec sa diversité
pour le dire de manière relativement
relativement pudique et ça c'est
encore traduit dans dans dans le texte
qui a été voté sur l'immigration en
filigradee alors ça c'est le ça c'est le
premier point ensuite euh
peut-être vous posez la même question un
peu que celle de Corine narassigin et de
audre nel sur la la situation
socio-économique de de la corrélation
entre les situations socio-économiques
difficiles et et et ses émeutes au-delà
j'ais dit j'allais dire de le origine
euh éventuellement sociale ou ou ou ou
ethnique
euh est-ce comment ça se comment ça se
construit est-ce que c'est vraiment
cette cette précarisation qui qui joue
également et là encore une fois il
s'agit de il s'agit d'un ensemble
d'éléments factuels pas d'éléments
d'excuse mais des de moyens d'objectiver
euh des euh des facteurs qui pourraient
amener à la deuxième chose c'est
peut-être aussi pour être plus euh
positif euh vous demandez en terme de
parce que là on fait l'identification de
ce qui ne de ce qui ne marche pas euh ou
de ce qui peut être amélioré dans notre
police mais en gros euh et je reviens à
certains de de vos travaux que que j'ai
parcouru peut-être nous faire part
d'expériences qui ont pu être menées à
l'étranger et qui contribuent à une
amélioration euh chercher une
amélioration de notre police c'est pas
dire qu'elle est c'est pas dire dire
fondamentalement qu'elle est mauvaise
mais c'est dire que manifestement il y a
des voies d'amélioration et que c'est
peut-être celle-ci qu'il faut chercher
sans chacun postuler qu'on a forcément
raison dans l'attitude qu'on a vis-à-vis
des forces de l'ordre qui par ailleurs
font leur métier c'est pas la question
la question c'est la question de de
l'orientation de l'utilisation de la
force publique et est-ce que cette
utilisation de la force publique elle
elle est
mieux faite ailleurs puis ma dernière
question c'est c'est de la curiosité
mais p sociologique c'est en terme de de
carrière et au terme là aussi au sens
sociologique du du terme on est on parle
de 2023 on parle de de de 2005 est-ce
que vous avez est-ce que vous pourriez
nous dire parce que aussi pour avoir une
idée ou pas positive des choses mais
est-ce que vous pourriez n donner une
une image de de de la trajectoire
ultérieure de ceux qui ont été concernés
par les émeutes de de de 2005 c'est quoi
leur futur c'est comment ils s'intègrent
ils deviennent des citoyens pour
reprendre un titre connu de broir et
tibéie est-ce qu'il redeviennent des
citoyens français comme les autres ou
est-ce que justement il y a toujours une
marginalité à part en gros ma question
vous l'avez compris est-ce que c'est un
moment ou est-ce que c'est une carrière
merci merci et Monsieur
benaroche Merci monsieur le Président
merci déjà de vos
analyses très intéressante pour
comprendre et pour envisager ce qui se
passe en dehors de l'événement précis
qui s'est passé mais aussi on le Ritu
dans un contexte qui est celui que vous
avez très bien décrit tous les trois et
je reviendrai sur deux points le premier
c'est les rapports avec la police vous
l'avez très bien dit le rapport avec la
politique pour tout un tas de gens qui
sont concernés c'est abord le rapport
avec la police bon et ce rapport avec la
police on l'a encore vu avec mes mes
collègues kouche ou Durin lors de la loi
d'orientation LM en 2023
le le problème des contrôles au fciess
je m'excuse d'y revenir parce que bon
finalement c'est facile de dire bon ben
oui ça existe depuis longtemps
finalement c'est pas si grave que ça
dans la réalité ça revient en permanence
moi je suis sénateur des bouchesd rô y
compris pendant la période covid ou en
tout cas pendant la période des masques
obligatoires c'est problèmes de contrôle
au fciè dans les rues de Marseille y
compris dans le centrre-ville parce que
Marseille a la particularité de pas de
d'avoir en quelque sorte les banlieux
dans le centre en fait bon c'est un peu
euh ont été particulièrement ressentis
et pratiqué donc je je je le dis parce
que c'est pas un problème qui a été
qu'on doit évacuer parce qu'il existe
encore et que rien n'a été pris et en
particulier par exemple après ces
émeudes aucune réflexion malgré tout ce
qui a pu être dit ici mais ailleurs
aussi et y compris par vous n'a été mené
sur ce sujet particulier des relations
avec la police et là effectivement comme
l'a dit rou il y a peut-être des
solutions on en propose tous aujourd'hui
sans avoir la certitude de pouvoir
modifier cette relation mais en sachant
que si on a modifie pas inexorablement
on se retrouvera confronté à des
problèmes liés à ces relation entre ces
personnes-là et la police et leur
sentiment de que que c'est par ce biais
là qu'en fait il juge notre société et
la politique de notre société ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième euh ce qui
m'a paru enfin qui qui qui m'interroge
et que je partage comme ça on va dire
euh euh d'une manière non euh argumentée
contrairement à vous c'est cette
relation entre les personnes qui se
trouvent au centre de ces de ces émeutes
et de ces périodes d'émeutes et le lien
avec la colonisation et avec le fait
qu'ils sont issus finalement beaucoup de
territoirees ce sont pas eux-mêmes mais
ce sont les enfants ou les
petits-enfants de gens qui viennent de
territoire qui étaient des colonies
françaises et c'est là où on rejou un
peu le problème de l'immigration et là
ça ça m'interroge parce que
effectivement ça ne recoupe pas
forcément vous l'avez dit aussi
euh le la situation socio-économique de
ces personnes là c'est c'est un autre
facteur c'est un autre c'est une autre
caractéristique marquante et je me
demande aujourd'hui si on a la
possibilité si vous avez déjà dans vos
études ou s'il existe à d'études qui ont
été mené qui fasse vraiment un lien
alors on va pas dire de causalité
directe mais un lien en tout cas
entre les les les gens les jeunes les
générations qui ont suivi la
décolonisation c'est-à-dire entre la
génération d'après puis la seconde puis
la 3isème
et le le à la fois on va dire
globalement la délinquance mais et les
émeutes et en particulier les émeutes
qui se produisent depuis quelques années
voilà je je sais pas je je le sens ce
lien vous l'avez exprimé je sais pas en
fait sur quoi il repose aujourd'hui et
comment on peut le le le le
caractériser merci Monsieur bénaroche
alors vous avez un certain nombre de
questions donc nous attendons un certain
nombre de
réponses moi je voudrais peut-être
compléter parce que je trouve qu'il y en
a pas assez de question mais non là de
la plaisanterie je voudrais compléter
euh sans trahir ou je parle sous le
contrôle des collègues qui ont assisté
quasiment à toutes les auditions jusqu'à
maintenant euh il nous a été dit que
effectivement
l'événement originel qui est la mort de
de Naël a déclenché évidemment un
processus mais qu'ensuite
euh les personnes qui ont été
interrogées alors c'est le rapport de
Ligas lis on est d'accord qui concerne
que les personnes qui ont été
judiciarisées très bien disent mais en
fait il y avait plus de lien après on
était passé à autre chose ce qui
n'exclut pas difficulté soulevé par Li
benaroche ou d'autres ici on était passé
à autre chose est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez mesuré pas du tout
ça fait partie de du package parce qu'en
fait on a l'impression que tout ça est
très multifactoriel il y a un fond il y
a un fond réel qui peut être d'ailleurs
sur plusieurs facteurs il y a un moment
où ça déclenche puis après ça passe à
autre chose donc l'idée c'est d'aller
comprendre un peu plus profondément ce
qui s'est passé en fait voilà je je me
tais pas qui veut commencer dans l'ordre
d'origine si vous changez c'est vous qui
reprenez monsieur Roch vous avez la
parolee toucher des points je cherche
pas y en a
beaucoup d'abord en 2005 comme en
2023 le le
territoire qui s'est enflammé c'est le
territoire des quartiers les plus
défavorisés donc le
Terrero qui conditionne l'flam
l'inflammation c'est celui-là bon
et comme en 2005 comme dans les autres
grandes émeutes le
l'étincelle c'est les c'est le le décès
c'estàd c'est c'est un homicide policier
bon et ça c'est quand même les deux
éléments structurels qu'on va retrouver
dans la plupart des pays qui sont
concernés par ces ces émeut ethnique
parce qu'il y a aussi des émeutes
politiques et j'ai cité la Grèce en 2008
qui peuvent avoir d'autres d'autres
motivations les émeutes de la fin comme
en Argentine mais sur ce type d' donc
moi je trouve qu'il y a un lien qui est
très fort parce que c'est des
territoires qui sont pauvres et
également exposé à des pratiques
policières agressives que certains pays
ont renoncé à avoir je pense par exemple
à l'Allemagne qui a une toute autre
approche des quartiers
défavorisés dans laquelle d'ailleurs les
codes de confiance de la police est
comparable à celle du reste de la ville
donc bon ça ça c'est quand même un lien
qui est fort maintenant et je pense
qu'il y a une transformation
effectivement de la nature du phénomène
puis qu'on a une succession de
phénomènes il y a un phénomène qui est
un incident qui provoque un
rassemblement qui provoque des
confrontations qui provoque une sorte de
soulèvement au cours duquel différents
groupes certains opportunistes vont
venir se mêler et l'histoire de la
sociologie des émeutes depuis les années
60 montre cette hétérogénéité
fondamentale des foules qui participent
aux émeutes il y a toujours eu cette
hétérogénéité il y a des hétérogénéités
dans les modes de participation il y en
a qui jetteent des cocktails
incendiaires sur la police d'autres nom
il y en a qui pillent d'autres nom il y
a une hétérogénéité de la composition et
il y a même une hétérogénéité qui varie
suivent le moment de la journée donc
c'est sûr qu'il y a une hétérogénéité de
de ce phénomène donc on va pas voilà on
va pas retrouver une une pureté mais
mais je pense qu'il y a des des formes
de de lien qui qui existent et qu'on
voit à travers les caractéristiques
structural voilà des des zones qui sont
particulièrement touchées je dirais je
je veux dire un autre un mot aussi sur
une autre point euh alors sur le qui m'a
étonné euh mais en sachant que j'ai pas
la réponse c'est la la correspondance
entre les gilets jaunes et les émeutes
c'està dire mais de quelle géographie on
parle ça serait ça ma question est-ce on
parle d'une géographie départementale ou
est-ce qu'on parle d'une géographie
communale parce que la géographie
départementale moi il me semble pas
qu'elle se ressemble j'ai fait la
géographie là sur les éutes de 2023 et
vraiment les les départements qui sont
pas touchés c'est la diagonale du vide
pas du tout touché donc je pense qu'il y
a peut-être des points de ressemblance
mais je suis pas persuadé que ce soit
complètement le cas et si on descendait
au niveau on une géographie non pas
départementale mais
communale et même infracommunale au
niveau des quartiers là je crois qu'on
aurait une géographie complètement
différente c'est qu'à l'intérieur des
villes les segments de villes qui sont
mobilisés ser seraient plus les mêmes
donc voilà et puis
dernier peut-être dernier
point sur
le estce que jeavais mis en gras
ou ça ça non moi je comme ça je vais
parler moins et puis je vais laisser mes
deux collègues dire ce qu'ils ont à dire
ça
reviendra monsieur Jobard ah oui
j'appuie sur le mauvais bouton
rouge je quelques quelques points très
rapides je voudrais revenir sur
l'événement déclencheur parce que moi
j'en vois trois à l'intérieur d'un même
événement il y a un tir il y a les j'en
vois quatre il y a un tir il y a le la
vidéo du tir il y a le son en fait dans
les heures qui ont suivi le tir se
répand l'idée que que le policier a dit
je vais te shooter ou quelque chose
semblable alors il y a eu des analyses
très détaillées qui ont été faites après
par des des des des associations des
services un peu spécialisés qui ont
montré que c'était pas si évident mais
il y a quelque chose de la de la menace
et donc d'un tir qui n'est pas
nécessaire il ne répond pas la à à à à à
ce que prévoit le droit notamment
légitime défense 4è point en fait ça
j'attire votre attention là-dessus hein
parce qu'on a quand même une institution
policière qui est défaillante à mon avis
sur cette question c'est que qui a
communiqué en premier sur le tir est-ce
le procureur de la République est-ce le
directeur départemental de la sécurité
publique des hautes scènes est-ce le
commissaire ou la commissaire de nanter
non c'est un syndicat de police c'est un
syndicat de police une fois de plus en
l'espèce Force Ouvrière unité euh SGP
unité Police Force Ouvrière bon qui a
dit bah ce matin un jeune qui avait
entrepris de je cite de mémoire mais en
gros c'était c'était ça he qui avait
entrepris pris de rouler sur un policier
euh a été tué des suites de la réplique
policière cette menace imminente de mort
et forcément quand la vidéo et du reste
c'est d'après ce que j'ai lu hein ce qui
a motivé la dame qui avait qui avait
filmé à diffusé cette vidéo en fait
c'est la fausse nouvelle et la question
que je pose c'est pourquoi diable le les
lorsqu'il y a un événement en zone
gendarmerie les gendarmes communiquent
comme des grands comme des grands et
lorsqu'il y a un événement en zone
police les syndicats euh communiquent je
veux dire je suis fonctionnaire comme
les policiers je suis syndiqué comme les
policiers parilleurs en ce moment je
suis élu euh enfin au sein de mon
organisation le CNRS euh je vous le
rappelle euh et euh mais moi mon
directeur mon président directeur
général il communique c'est pas moi qui
communique pour l'établissement euh bon
donc là il y a quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas parce que euh je rappelle
par exemple la mort de
euh la mort du jeune Souheil à Marseille
euh en août 2021 qui communique sur
cette sur cette mort hein par donc une
balle tirée par un policier qui a touché
le cœur du du du jeune homme euh bien
c'était le le même syndicat Unité force
ouvriè il y a quelque chose qui ne va
pas là-dedans parce que je pense que la
communication des pouvoirs publics
serait une communication plus mesurée
euh serait une communication plus
balancée une communication qui serait
moins affirmative et qui appellerait à
la patience à l'examen et un rendez-vous
avec les pouvoirs publics
euh donc ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose voyez mon Éric
kouche notre collègue j'allais
dire nous interpelle sur les meilleures
manières de faire celle-ci en est une
pas très compliqué
euh deuxème point sur lequel je voulais
intervenir le sur votre intervention
madame qui qui qui qui nous dit que
cette fois les les populations n'en
peuvent plus et ne veulent plus payer
euh je je pense que elle ne voulait pas
plus payer et elle n'est pas elle
n'était pas plus heureuse en 2005 et les
les témoignages qu'on a faudrait revenir
sur Ina.fr pour écouter un petit peu la
tonalité des reportages qui avaient été
menés dans les cités à l'époque mais
cette angoisse de voir cette angoisse de
voir son véhicule brûlé euh et être
privé dans un certain nombre de communes
notamment cell par exemple en
Île-de-France qui qui qui sont
périphériques à la le premier employeur
d'île-de-francece maintenant que nous
n'avons plus d'industrie en
Île-de-France et aéroport de Paris on
est dépendant de la voiture en fait pour
aller travailler l'exaspération elle est
la même en 2005 mais un sentiment
n'évacue pas un autre et c'est ça la la
la une dimension importante à à à saisir
c'est
que un certain nombre de ceux qui disent
le exaspération
euh on on peut-être rejoint les rangs
des ametiers 20 ans avant ce sont leurs
enfants qui sont sur le qui étaient sur
le bitum fin juin début juillet et je
reviendrai d'ailleurs sur la notion la
notion de carrière ils sont exaspérés
pourquoi parce qu'on brûle leur voiture
bien sûr mais aussi parce qu'il y a une
mécanique qui est la même que celle en
2005 consiste à voir une une action
policière ce qu'ils identifie à tort
cette fois-ci en 2023 comme une mauvaise
réponse des pouvoirs publics un
sentiment d'abandon un sentiment
d'injustice et une révolte des jeunes je
veux dire au fond dire je n'en peux plus
c'est dire je n'en peux plus de quoi
exactement bien sûr je ne veux pas que
mon véhicule soit soit
incendié mais ça ne ça n'est pas un
sentiment exclusif euh d'un d'un d'un
certain nombre d'autres prises de de
position et pour être très clair les
territoires dans lesquels nous avons eu
euh les territoires dans lesquels on
recrute les les les populations
ameetières quand on mène des enquêtes de
de victimation comme mon centre de
recherche le fait depuis plus de 20 ans
notamment les enquêtes de victimation
sur l'île-france et ben on se rend
compte que les populations les plus
pauvres du valdarne ou de la saine
Saint-Denis sont caractérisées par deux
choses la PR pardon par trois choses la
première euh un niveau d'atteinte et de
délinquence euh qui est euh parmi le
plus élevé en île-de-fance à Paris il y
a beaucoup de délinquantces également
mais la deuxième caractéristique
valdemarne les cités les plus les les
les villes les plus pauvres de valdear
et de la SA sainten c'est qu'il y a une
très forte demande de police très forte
demande de police la demande de police
en Île-de-France la plus élevée elle est
sur les territoires qui ont été en
premier touchés par les émeutes
mais simplement cette demande de police
s'accompagne également d'un taux très
fort que que Sébastien a évoqué tout à
l'heure d'un satisfaction à l'égard de
la police et donc si vous voulez c'est
pas un un on nassiste pas à une
sécession des population là-bas
vis-à-vis de l'autorité là je ne suis
pas d'accord avec votre point de vue au
contraire il y a une demande de présence
de de de l'État police sans doute aussi
d'ailleurs d'école et cetera il y a une
demande de police mais il y a la demande
d'une meilleure police d'une police
autre la demande d'un autre service
public de sécurité et donc si vous
voulez il n'est jamais trop tard
pour ajuster l'offre à la demande le le
là où il est trop tard c'est a plus de
demande du tout vous prenez des
territoires tels
[Musique]
que rien de meilleur me vient en tête
malheureusement prenez les États-Unis
enfin bon les États-Unis c'est pas les
villes aux États-Unis au milieu du 19 9
siècle si vous voulez pas de demande de
police on fait sa chacun fait sa police
soi-même le patron il fait sa police
dans son usine le les villageois ils
élisent un tel et un tel et allez hop
ils vont faire la police c'est ce qu'on
appelle les milices d'autodéfense le
vigilantisme les milices bourgeoises
qu'on avait nous au 17e 18e siècle chez
nous là oui là il y a une sécession mais
il y a demande de police
là-bas
[Musique]
je j'ai peur d'être pardon trè point sur
le colonisation colonie et CEA c'est
vieux tout
ça c'est vieux et c'est vous vous parlez
pour le coup je je suis livré main de
fois à l'expérience vous parlez de de de
de des colonies une situation
post-coloniale et cetera à des policiers
qui sont en exercice en Île-de
France ça ne fait pas de sens bien sûr
mais là il faut quand même faut quand
même adopter un un un un point un peu un
peu historique macro et je vais je vais
être très bref vous nous dites madame
vience policière il y a pas que ça je
suis tout à fait d'accord il a pas que
ça dans la vie en particulier dans le au
cœur du problème qu'on aborde
aujourd'hui il y a pas que ça du tout
mais il se trouve qu'on a eu en France
et c'est ça une singularité très forte
de la France en grande partie aussi de
la Grande-Bretagne c'est qu'on a eu
successivement des colonisations alors
en France une guerre coloniale
particulièrement violente et longue car
en Algérie ça et cette guerre parce que
le FLN l'a exporté en en sur le
territoire métropolitain elle s'est
déroulé également sur notre sol ici et
notamment préfecture de police euh à
cette guerre à succéder euh et ben le
rapatriement de tout un ensemble de
populations euh très diverses de ces
paysl la France là aussi grosse
différence par rapport à l'Angleterre 1
million de d'Européens non musulmans en
en Algérie hein c'est c'est considérable
on a ratrié tous beau monde et en gros
alors je vais très vite hein
pardonnez-moi il y a pas d'historien
dans la salle euh en gros on a confié la
gestion de ces populations euh aux
euh forces de l'ordre qui avaient exercé
euh en Afrique du Nord ou qui avait
exercé la préfecture de police carrière
de pour reprendre le terme de carrière
la carrière de Maurice Papon est
intéressante de ce point de vue là on
lui confie le Constantinois on lui
confie la préfecture de police et vous
voyez là il y a une continuité
post-coloniale qui s'arrête pas en 1962
et là où alors la la trajectoire
française euh est vraiment pas très
chanceuse c'est que la France est un
pays qui a choisi un modèle de
développement économique qui est un
modèle fondé sur le tertiaire autrement
dit la
désindustrialisation à partir du milieu
des années 70 petit à petit ça grignote
grosse manifestation cidérurgiste pour
ceux qui s'intéressent à l'histoire du
maintien de l'ordre euh 2è moitié des
années 70 hein bah on a plus d'industrie
en France euh moi il se trouve que j'ai
fait un stage ouvrier à hnet sousbois en
19 90 il y avait encore 3500 ouvriers à
hen à l'époque aujourd'hui il y en a
zéro euh et quelles sont les populations
qui sont touchées par la
désindustrialisation c'est pas moi c'est
pas nous ce sont les populations
masculines sorties du système scolaire
sans qualification et donc si vous
voulez qu'est-ce qui la quelle dynamique
se met en œuvre le policier il gère en
le policier francilien on va dire il
gère euh il gère les populations
nord-africaines dans un contexte de
guerre sur le territoire jusqu'en 62
puis il gère l'installation à un rythme
effrainé l'implantation de commissariat
n au bois ça devit être une brigade
territoriale de gendarmerie en 1965 hein
donc on on installe des commissariats de
police les commissariats de police ont
ont fait appel à des commissaires qui
ont été formé soit la préfecture soit en
Afrique du Nord et après il se retrouve
avec une population masculine oisive euh
de plus en plus massive parce que qui
absorbe la population masculine sans
diplôme c'est l'industrie il y a plus
d'industrie et ces jeunes-là sont dans
la rue et si vous voulez pour les
policiers bah il y a une grande cont
pour les policiers pour je dirais pour
l'institution policière un peu
d'ailleurs pour pour la société une
certaine continuité des années 60 à
aujourd'hui de une population qui pose
problème mais c'est un modèle économique
derrière c'est une trajectoire
économique c'est une trajectoire
politique et effectivement là de ce
point de vue-là vous avez raison de dire
que les violances policières c'est
périphérique les violances policières ça
n'est jamais que la conséquence de ça
mais çaen a une très forte à laquelle
aujourd'hui on se raccroche c'est un peu
une métonymie si vous voulez de de cette
histoire de cette histoire euh macro
social qui touche les quartiers dont on
parle Merci à
VOUS
euh si vous voulez vous nêtes pas obligé
ououi bien sûr je je veux bien je suis
venu pour ça euh peut-être que la
première question à laquelle je voudrais
répondre c'est autour de la place du
trafic de drogue euh et du rôle des des
cadres des cadres locaux du trafic de
drogue euh pour le dire rapidement c'est
c'est c'est vraiment un rôle qui est
extrêmement fantasmé je voudrais
rappeler que le le pour fonctionner
trafic de drogue notamment local visible
dans l'espace public il a besoin d'être
régulé il a besoin d'ordre euh il a
besoin de de
de de de pouvoir euh
euh fonctionner il a besoin de pouvoir
mettre en sécurité la clientèle pour
pouvoir organiser la la la la
distribution de manière apaisée il a
besoin de développer de la force de
ventre il a besoin de stabilité le trafi
le trafiquant de drogue et les les
émeutes et les révoltes sont tous sa
cette forme de de stabilité donc il
aspire pas du tout à l'émeute au point
d'aller jusqu'au déclenchement c'est les
acteurs qui peuvent de manière hors
émeute nationale qui peuvent
ponctuellement mettre des coups de
pression exercer leur pouvoirs en
mettant la pression sur tel acteur tel
institution ça c'est possible c'est des
choses qu'on peut voir mais hors du
cadre de de de des révoltes et et et et
des émeutes et j'ai même envie de dire
que il a fort à perdre à s'opposer à une
dynamique de colère collective ou
desémeutes il peut y laisser beaucoup de
plumes en terme de de de de légitimité
de de statut et de et de ce pouvoir qui
est qui est toujours très fragile donc
je pense qu'on on on amplifie on
fantasme un peu sur la question du
pouvoir sur un quartier des des des des
trafiquants notamment pendant ces
périodes ces périodes d'M et puis j'ai
envie de dire il y a une partie des
trafiquants qui est totalement tout à
fait
compréhensif à l'égard des raisons de la
colère et parfois il les partage donc
euh bon bah euh il peut négocier pour
que bah les affrontements se fassent pas
forcément dans l'accès à son point de
d'î mais c'est le maximum qu' pourra
obtenir euh à l'échelle à l'échelle
locale euh autre point sur lequel je
voudrais revenir sur sur la la la
mobilisation la notion d'autorité que
vous avez fait
euh moi je pense que dans les rapports
entre cette partie de la population et
la la police c'est pas un un rejet de
l'autorité c'est une prise au sérieux de
l'autorité c'est une parole qui qui est
prise au sérieux c'est la parole de de
l'État c'est une parole officielle c'est
une parole
institutionnelle c'est pas un rejet ou
une espèce de posture ou de discours
anarchiste qui serait derrière le
rapport avec l'autorité policière
l'autorité policière elle est là elle
est pas remise en question en tant que
tel son existence mais c'est ces
pratiques qui sont massivement remises
en question d'où là une demande de
meilleure police d'où un problème de
confiance avec l'actuelle police et d'où
une prise au sérieux d'où ces effets
cette colère et le partage ces
mobilisations collectives parce que
c'est une parole qui est prise une prise
au sérieux c'est la même chose avec
alors c'est un peu différent mais avec
les enseignants et tous les
représentants de l'État c'est des
paroles qui sont prises au au sérieux et
puis avec les enseignants je suis désolé
mais la grande majeure partie des des
parents qui sont issus des quartiers
populaires respectent leurs enseignants
sont attachés à leur école poussent
leurs enfants faudrait quand même qu'on
arrête de construire cette image
complètement déformée de la réalité
d'une population qui serait hostile à à
à l'école par contre une partie des
jeunes pour pour qui l'école a été un
lieu de de souffrance un lieu
extrêmement compliqué qu'ils ont pu
traverser et là oui on peut avoir des
des des des formes de déviant scolaire
des formes de transgression d'opposition
à l'institution qui sont lié au rapport
à l'institution d'une partie d'une
petite fraction des des adolescents et
non pas des parents de manière générale
dont on parle un autre mot sur les
parents qui sera intéressant tout à
l'heure Sébastien Rocher a montré les
une courbe assez régulière de de
d'meutes nationales qui qui qui don dont
le le les P d'intensité se font dans les
premiers jours et on s'est dit peut-être
que l'hypothèse pourquoi ça s'arrête
parce que peut-être que les les gens se
fatiguent oui la question de l'usure et
est là mais il y a surtout ce que j'ai
pu observer sur le terrain qui a été
mentionné tout à l'heure des gens qui se
mobilisent sur le terrain des gens dont
on parle peu des gens qui sont pas qui
sont pas très visibles mais des gens qui
se mobilisent sur le terrain et en
premier lieu les parents parfois en
organisant des brigades jusqu'à pas
d'heure en lançant les les les les en
laissant les enfants à la maison on a
les travailleurs sociaux les éducateurs
les animateurs mais moi j'en ai
interrogé beaucoup ces derniers temps et
c'est vrai qu'une partie d'entre eux euh
a attendu quelques jours avant de sortir
pour laisser cette colère s'exprimer
parce que c'est une colère qu'il partage
même s'il condamne les manières de
détruire les bâtiments publics ils
condamnent le fait de s'en prendre au
véhicule de leurs voisins ils condamnent
toutes ces dégradations mais ils
comprennent la colère ils comprennent
c'est une colère et qui entend cette
colère eux-mêmes en tant que parents et
ça c'est depuis des décenes c'est comme
ça en tant que parents ils ont fait
remonter cette colère souvent leur
interlocuteur c'est le maire ils en
parlent au maire le maire il a pas
pouvoir direct sur la police nationale
ensuite il remontre à travers les les
les travailleurs sociaux ont fait
remonter cette colère il la font
remonter au préfet ils la font remonter
au au aux élus au maire et parfois des
membres du gouvernement qui sont de
passage cette parole là elle a été
relayée également par des collectifs de
victimes de violence policière
d'association la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme enfin plein d'association
d'organisation de défense des droits
humains le défenseur de des droits
institutions publiques donc un certain
nombre d'élus de personnel politique a
fait remonter cette parole et qu'est-ce
qui est fait de cette parole par les
gouvernements successifs c'est ça la
question qui est fondamentale il me
semble et qui fait que on reproduit tout
temps la même la même histoire avec les
mêmes les mêmes effets avec les mêmes
conséquences et et et et on se
réinterroge régulièrement sur qu'est-ce
qui fait que on est autant de de de de
de violence oui il y a des petites évol
mais on était tous les trois mobilisés
en 2005 on a tous les tous les trois
écrit des choses en 2005 faut pas croire
qu'on va écrire des choses radicalement
différente que ce de ce qu'on a observé
en
2005 et dernier point sur la mobilité ça
été dit tout à l'heure mais vous avez
dit bon c'est des jeunes de leur
quartier qui qui brûlent en bas de chez
eux en fait non il y a beaucoup de
mobilité ceux qui ont brûlé dans le
quartier a n'habitait pas forcément le
quartier a et peut-être le quartier B
c'estd que les groupes de jeunes les
grappes de jeunes et la manière don
s'est organisé euh euh se sont organisé
ou pas en tout cas se sont déployés ces
ces ces ces ces violences euh et et
c'était basé sur un principe de mobilité
effectivement on avait des jeunes locaux
qui se sont mobilisés mais on avait des
gens qui venaient d'autres quartiers
d'autres territoires euh et ça on l'a
observé dans beaucoup beaucoup de
départements et notamment de de de
départements d'Île-de-France et puis un
mot sur le
rapport de de l'IGA igj et toutes les
données qu'on a sur le profil des
émetiers qui sont déférés finalement qui
sont mis en cause interpellés qui sont
déférés c'est les perdants c'est les
amateurs qui se font attraper en premier
pour le dire très très rapidement euh
euh les plus tactiques les plus
organisés eux c'est la PJ ou la sûreté
départementale qui va enquêter ça va
prendre des mois et il commencecent à
peine à se faire interpeller c'est pas
du tout le même public ceux qui se font
avoir c'est beaucoup ceux qui ont saisi
qui ont qu'une expérience qui ont pas
d'expérience de l'opposition avec les
forces de l'ORD d'ailleurs les étud de
la PGJ l'étude flash de la PGJ sur les
mineurs déférés montre que près de 70 %
sont n' aucun antécédent judiciaire
c'est à peu près la même chose en en
2005 68,2 de primes délinquant qui ont
aucun entécédent judiciaire parmi les
mineurs qui ont été
déférés en fin juin fin juin
début début juillet donc c'est vraiment
un public qui participe pour plein de
raisons mais qui n'a aucune expérience
de ces de ces
mobilisations
merci messieurs je crois qu'on a terminé
avec cette audition vous remerci d'être
contributeur aux réflexions de cette
mission d'information et puis on vous
rend à à vos réflexions à vos travaux
merci